I actually did have a fair moment at the
airport always care in the airport yes
you know how they separate the lines
yeah I know a ruby group right I had a
first class ticket I was running kind of
late right and then this lady was like
trying to tell me like oh they're only
calling first class first yeah
and then I'm like I am and I walked by
they didn't register until I got down I
was thinking oh she probably thought I
was cutting why did she think that and
it was like oh she didn't think you
could afford it I could afford it
because of how I look I look homeless
yes
but that must be the best feeling
knowing that oh this has no idea
you just let them run their mouth and
you just know I'm about to pull draw
four right now
here pass sure bam oh my God I didn't
know he stole it yeah I was like who
does that looks at you and assumes it's
not your turn yet it is my turn
you're a pass then for you